[Music]  so you're still running your parents  frogger store that is adorable  as soon as the insurance money comes in  this place will look good as new  susan caldwell  she wrecked my shop oh that corporate  butt sniffer and i have a polyamorous  date with my punching fist  getting on forge's super successful  dirty 30 is a lifelong dream it's  irrefutable proof to the rest of the  world that octavia wallace star  exists  that i'm a somebody you however are not  on this list you're anonymous  unrecognized and nobody  we use innovation and technology to help  people and protect life not casually  destroy it as a matter of course  you're a revolutionary boss we are on  the cusp of a world  with less bloodshed  we could  change the world for the better get rich  and famous kick susan caldwell's ass  let's take the fight to them just tell  me who to shoot and where to shoot him  are you flirting with me  you are dead now that's a pitch  [Music]